j'accueille julien clerc
bonsoir
j'ai à vous le connaissiez les françois
mitterrand il dînait deux fois chez vous
ouais puis je suis allé quelques fois à
l'elysée c'était des dîners de vous des
déjeuners très gaie et une fois où il
avait accueilli baby doc en france et
vous le dit quand même c'est un peu
scandait le nom qui lui dit sa renault
qui dira ça la fout mal
un président de gauche et accueillir
cette ordure plus qu'un jour renault est
votre top heidi belge
je ne peux pas le voyez il l'a gardé
voyez le regarder et mazarine nous
l'avait rencontrée mais je crois qu'on
est en vérité je crois que oui je pense
deux fois en fait une fois quand le
chantait au rex et une autre fois à
l'elysée où je crois même qu avec sa
maman effectivement elle devait elle
aimait bien y avait des chanteurs
qu'elle aimait bien mais arrive un jour
et je crois qu'il y avait effectivement
vous êtes bien la rencontre et de viser
mais sans le savoir sur bien